is deeply concerned about the
uh
the barbarism that we've seen in the new
focus of that
barbarism by vladimir putin in the
donbass region
particularly his brutal offensive
against mario paul
which is why yesterday i announced we'd
be sending more artillery and doing
everything possible to help the people
of ukraine defend themselves
in those areas
and at the same time the extraordinary
fortitude and the success of president
zlensky and the ukrainian people
in resisting russian forces in kiev
means that i can announce today that we
will very shortly
next week reopen our embassy in
ukraine's capital city
i want to pay
tribute to those british diplomats
who remained elsewhere in the region
throughout this period
the
united kingdom and our allies
will not watch passively as putin
carries on
this onslaught and
what i think we've seen uh here in
new delhi is
one of the world's oldest democracies
and
the world's largest democracy
sticking together
and
confronting our shared anxieties about
autocracies and autocratic coercion
around the world and acting together to
make our country safer and more
prosperous
our new and expanded defense and
security partnership
will enable
india to strengthen its own domestic
defense industry as well as protecting
vital shared interests in the
indo-pacific
our collaboration on energy security
including our new offer on offshore wind
the new uk india hydrogen science and
innovation hub and our joint work on
solar power
i will help to reduce
our collective dependence on imported
hydrocarbons in favor of cheaper and
more sustainable home-grown renewables
and our global innovation partnership
will help transfer climate and energy
smart innovations to developing
countries around the wider indo-pacific
as we deepen the partnership between our
countries we won't just make our people
safer
we'll make them more prosperous as well
creating new jobs
driving up wages and driving down prices
for consumers all of which helps with
the cost of living
and
our partnership with
india is particularly powerful in
achieving these things because
india
is
an incredible rising power in asia one
of the fastest growing economies in the
world already worth 2.25 trillion pounds
and set to be the world's third largest
the world's third largest economy by
2050. india
is also our biggest partner in the
indo-pacific which is increasingly the
geopolitical center of the world with
two-thirds of humanity and a third of
the global economy and that share is
rising every year indian investment
already supports almost half a million
british jobs
and with a population bigger than the us
and the eu combined there is so much
potential for us to take our trade and
investment to a whole new level
on this visit alone we've secured
new deals
worth a billion pounds
creating more than 11 000 jobs
and perhaps most significantly of all
we're using our brexit freedoms to reach
a bilateral free trade agreement and
today prime minister modi and i told our
negotiators to get it done by diwali in
october
this could double our trade and
investment by the end of the decade
driving down prices for consumers and
increasing wages across the uk by as
much as 3 billion pounds
so what we're getting on with here is
delivering on the priorities of the
british people but also
deepening a friendship with a nation
with whom we have profound ties of
language culture and kinship while
making both our countries safer and our
economies stronger
we're going to take a few questions from
the
media and
we have uh we're going to go first to
some uk journalists and then uh to uh
some of our our indian colleagues so
first of all
can i go to ben wright of the bbc
thank you thank you prime minister
in your discussions about ukraine did
you ask prime minister modi to use his
influence in moscow to put pressure
on russia and did you get any sense that
he would do that
and
on trade you said there'll be a free
trade agreement with india by diwali but
considering the number of party
investigations going on back home are
you absolutely sure you'll still be
prime minister then um okay the second
answer is yes uh but on the um
on your on your your point about um
[Music]
ukraine and and the indian perspective
look i mean
i think you have to recognize that
the
uh
the
indians have actually in uh and uh
narendra modi in particular have have
come out and
been very strong in their language about
what's happened in uh in butcher and
talking to
narendra prime minister modi today it's
it's clear
that he has already intervened several
times
and i'm sure this is no secret from uh
our indian friends he's intervened
several times with uh with vladimir
putin really to ask him what you know
what on earth he thinks he's doing
and where he thinks this is going
and what the indians want is is peace
and they want uh the russians out and uh
i
totally agree with that
and i think that
you know there's a there's a difference
in the
uh in the balance
clearly because india has a historic
relationship with uh with russia which
everybody understands and respects that
goes back
that goes back decades but you know what
was so interesting about the last couple
of days has been the way in which
britain and india
are being
really
encouraged
obliged by the pressure of events
today
as i say autocratic coercion uh whether
it's in uh russia or china or wherever
uh to
do more together
and and that is and that is i think a
uh offering up a huge huge joint agenda
and there are three three big areas
where you're seeing
uh work being done now they're on the
uh
green growth side
big big agenda for us uh clean power
uh and a lot of work is being done on
that
they're on the security and defense side
and a a huge amount there which i i i
could go into and then of course on the
on the trade agreement and there i think
yeah you know all trade agreements are
tricky ben to get your your point about
trade but
um
and there will be there will be tough
asks of both sides but i'm sure we can
do it and what you got today
was a massive push
in the
from the from both governments uh to get
it done and so i'm i'm i'm very i'm very
very encouraged
anushka astana itv
so thank you
um
you say that prime minister modi
has
asked vladimir putin what on earth he's
doing
but
we know that india has now stayed on
motions at the um over this its foreign
secretary has just come out and said you
didn't put any pressure on india to
change its position why isn't that what
did the prime minister say that
convinced you more
74 of the british public think you're
untrustworthy only 12
think you're trustworthy some say you're
like a cat with nine lives how many have
you got left
um well uh anushka on your on your
second question uh you know we had a
talking about cats we had a you know
pretty good uh kick of the cat uh
yesterday uh
not that i'm in favor of kicking cats
for the avoidance of diet uh but um you
know we did all that we great respect
and uh what were
what we're talking about today is as i
said in my answer to
to ben
is uh the the ways in which the the
situation not just in ukraine the
situation around the world is obliging
the uk and india to do more together and
uh the
the position on your your position on uh
russia that the indians have
historically is is well known uh that
they are not going to to change that of
course that's true
uh but they are you know they can see
what is going on and uh there is
an increasing appetite to do more with
the uk and if if you look at what uh
justin just in the security and defense
uh side of it uh
on
maritime propulsion electric maritime
propulsion of of of ships on new uh
collaboration on new aero engines on
uh
on undersea uh capabilities uh on uh on
cyber
uh helicopters space
uh a huge new uh joint agenda
and that is being driven by contemporary
events and i think it's a it's a
a positive thing it's a it's a it's a
great opportunity and it's fully and
what it does is it helps to to drive the
uh the make in india agenda
uh of uh prime minister modi
uh but also helps to to drive the idea
of of co-production
and and doing things together uh and
that's where i think the opportunity is
hugo hugo guy the i
thank you prime minister you've made it
clear you don't want to talk about
questions over your future and and over
your conduct but
it's also clear that voters are
interested in this polls have repeatedly
showed that voters are deeply concerned
about
about downing street parties and about
your position what what's your message
to the british public
are they wrong to care about these
things um and can i ask you you've
talked about your friendship with
narendra modi and the close relationship
um that you've struck
during your conversations did you bring
up india
so we we always have uh so it's on your
first
uh point hugo look i think that
what people want in uh in our country is
for the government to get on and focus
on the issues on which we were elected
and that's what we're going to do and i
think they'll be particularly interested
in uh
jobs growth in the uk uh
a
memorandum of understanding for instance
today
on on wind power gigantic ambitions for
uh more more wind energy uh both of us
from offshore wind offshore and not just
offshore but floating platforms we want
to uh to work on together uh to produce
substantial quantities of
of new wind power which will enable us
to produce more energy for our people
together in a very short time that
strikes me as being a reasonable thing
for the government of the uk to focus on
that is what we are uh focused on with
greatest respect to uh to you know the
evidence that you uh you may cite and uh
secondly um on the
our relations with india and you know
how we uh how we deal with with uh
questions about human rights or
democratic values of course we have
these conversations but they the the the
advantage of our uh of our friendship is
we can have them and we can have them in
a friendly and uh and private way and i
just i just want to say on on
you know it is very important to realize
india has constitutional uh protections
uh for communities uh they're part of
its its constitution uh india uh is is a
very very different country from uh
autocracies around the world it is it is
a great great democracy and that's why
and you know it is a stunning shining
fact 1.35 billion people who live under
a democracy and that's something we
should celebrate and it offers us a an
opportunity for uh for closer
cooperation and partnership that doesn't
mean i'm not going to raise
uh
tough consular questions as as i have
today
and other difficult questions of course
we do that but we do that as friends
okay makes